i'll be the first to admit that  sometimes litigation is bananas and such  was the case in the epic versus  apple litigation that's going forward  right now when the parties had to  discuss  one of the fortnite characters pili who  happens to be a banana  and things got hilarious from there a  lawyer for apple introduced the issue we  have a large yellow banana here in a  tuxedo  and the witness replies yes that's peely  the apple lawyer says  we thought it was better to go with a  suit instead of the naked banana because  we're in federal court right now  and then the epic lawyer chimes in there  might have been an implication that  showing peely without a suit might have  been inappropriate  is there anything inappropriate about  peely without clothes to which the  witness replied  it's just a banana man because sometimes  it's just a banana now i'm sure that  this is not the last we've heard of this  banana because this case is surely to be  appealed  unless it gets too slippery